hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
chapter 11 of richard dawkins book the
selfish gene
introduces the concept or the notion
of the meme and it's there's a couple
interesting features to point out about
that
right off the bat it's been a while
since dawkin
introduced this term and
even when he introduced it it wasn't
really a radically new idea
there are analogs to this in the
writings of many other people
antidating dawkins to talk about how it
is that
culture and ideas
and practices are replicated
transmitted and reinterpreted we're
going to put that to the side
the other thing we have to point out as
well for
viewers and and listeners who are
you know used to the use of the word
meme in a somewhat different
context that of the internet the word
does originate
with richard dawkins but then it
interestingly like a meme
takes on a life of its own and comes to
mean
a set of other things within the sphere
of the internet could this be
understood and explained on the basis of
dawkins notion
of a meme yes i think it could that's
another
separate issue a bigger issue that we're
going to put aside for the moment here
let's figure out what does he
actually mean by meme and he
apologizes for introducing
this term he says that i hope my
classes friends will forgive me
if i abbreviate it if it's any
consolation etc etc right so he's
he's saying i'm deliberately introducing
a
we could call it metacultural unit in
here
and he says we need a name for the new
replicator
a noun that conveys the idea of a unit
of cultural transmission or a unit of
imitation so he turns to greek and he
takes
mimim right coming from the greek term
mimesis which means
imitation and mimesis has been
associated
not just with imitation or mimicry but
also with
artistic and indeed other types of
production
since the time of plato who talks about
art as mimesis right so
this is a idea a word that's that's you
know got some long-standing
credibility dawkin wants to
abbreviate it because he likes a nice
monosyllabic
word like gene something like that so
meme is what he forms he clips off the
you know first part of it which is you
know kind of interesting because it's
uh reducing it in in its its uh
you could say its size in its syllabic
content but also
maybe stripping off a little bit of its
older conception
he says um if it's any consolation it
could
alternatively be thought of as being
related to
memory name in in greek right
uh and it's there's a lot that could be
said about the connection between
mimesis and memory
in ancient philosophy onward and then he
says aura could be related to the french
word
meme which means same
among other things right and he says it
should be pronounced to rhyme with
cream very good that he gave us that
because otherwise we'd probably
wind up in the same sort of quandary
that the inventor
of the gif right or the gif depending on
how people want to pronounce it the
adventure actually did weigh in and say
eventually it's jif not gif but there's
there's a lot of people
who uh you know go to verbal war over
that so
meme he's he's given us the term
what does a meme mean what is the notion
of a meme he starts out first by giving
us
a bunch of examples and what do these
include tunes
ideas catchphrases closed
fashions ways of making pots or building
arches
and he says just as jeans propagate
themselves in the gene pool by leaping
from body to body
memes propagate themselves by leaping
from brain to brain
if a scientist hears or reads about a
good idea he passes the idea
on to his colleagues and the the
examples that dawkins
is going to use in this chapter fit into
those so you know the idea of god for
example right
that's an idea he brings up tunes he
asks the question
is uh an entire symphony a meme or is
the da
da a symphony a particular
meme and you might actually think of the
uh
test for that as the old show
um you know name that tune where you
would you would have to bid
on how few notes would be played before
you could identify
that as that tune right so
you know for example i could say
what tune is that well running with the
devil by van halen of course right
that's not enough to be a meme except
within
a circumstance if you're with fellow
metal heads
and you started doing that probably a
lot of them would catch on
you know whereas if you're doing that in
the larger public maybe nobody would
actually know what you're doing so
memes might also be to some degree
dependent on particular context to be
identifiable
and to work as memes so he's got all
these examples and
these tie in with the examples of
cultural reproduction that he was giving
earlier
language fashion and dress and diet we
could think of
dishes perhaps as memes right or flavor
profiles as
memes ceremonies and customs art and
architecture engineering
and technology all these things that
evolve all of them evolve
he thinks on the basis of memes and they
do propagate themselves as he says
from brain to brain right they he
actually uses the word
parasitizing uh we might think of them
also as sort of like
viral to use a term that we use today
and he goes on and he says when you
plant a
fertile meme in my mind you literally
parasitize my brain turning it into a
vehicle for the memes propagation
in just the way that a virus may
parasitize the genetic mechanism of a
host cell
maybe that's going a little bit too far
because there could be other modes
maybe it's not all like you know viral
stuff
and he says this isn't just a way of
talking the meme for
say belief in life after death is
actually realized physically millions
and times over as a structure in the
nervous systems of individual
men the whole world over now so this is
quite interesting
and this should you know raise some
questions at this point
that we'll have to look at a little bit
later like
the idea of life after death is that
really a meme war
is the idea of reincarnation
as opposed to the idea of going to a
good place or a bad place or the idea of
just going to
kind of a crappy place unless you happen
to be lucky enough to
be reincarnated with flawless or
with huitsapocaly these are all
different
notions of life after death are they
separate memes is
to take one example uh the
nine levels the nine circles of dante's
inferno
are is each one of them a meme is each
type of
torture a meme or is the
totality itself a meme how general can
memes be life after death that's pretty
vague
the notion of god is he's going to talk
about that's a pretty vague idea too is
that really a meme
or is it something different well this
is not
answered very well in this chapter where
he's in
introducing this idea but it's something
that could be
worth um checking out and
he brings up how this propagation works
he says that um consider the idea of god
we don't know how it arose in the meme
pool probably it originated many times
by independent mutation
in any case it is very old indeed how
does it replicate itself here's where it
gets interesting
by the spoken and written word aided by
great music
and a great art later on he'll talk
about church services
and the different aspects the different
rituals the different
design features as being parts of meme
complexes that would be connected with
god
and you know it seems like there's a lot
of different moving parts here
so he says what is it about the idea of
god that gives it its stability and
penetrance in the cultural environment
the survival value of the god meme and
the meme pool
results from its great psychologically
great psychological appeal it provides a
superficially plausible answer to deep
and troubling questions
about existence and so he goes on from
there god exists if only in the form of
a meme with high survival value
or infective power in the environment
provided by human culture now there's
there's a lot of
hand waving going on here in a lot of
reductivist
tendencies and dawkins is not really
somebody to be
believed much when it comes to analyses
of religion but there's something here
maybe if we think about
ideas of god or the gods or
different competing conceptions
pantheism versus panentheism versus
monotheism
understood in different ways are we
talking about classical theism
are we talking about open theism each of
these could be perhaps a meme
and then how do we explain their
continuance well they
they must have some sort of appeal
that's how they get into
brains and so he goes on and he
considers the analogy between
memes and genes he had said
earlier that there's really three main
things that are involved in imitation
replication whether it be dna or memes
longevity fecundity and copying fidelity
what does longevity mean in this this
case
he says that the longevity of any one
copy of a meme is probably
relatively unimportant as it is for any
one copy of a gene
and he gives uh in the example the song
old lang zine which
people sing or whistle or hum
at new years right that someone let old
acquaintance be
forgot because nobody actually knows the
rest of the words except for two people
but they do know the tune
and then we get to the chorus oh for old
lang syne right and that's the other
part that people know which goes to show
you that you don't actually have to like
have
great copying fidelity of people
can't remember half of the words to the
to the song that he's actually
using there and how long did that meme
last
it lasted while it was in the air while
we were referring to it
but it's also up in our heads occupying
some space whether you realize it or not
if you recognized
that song right so that's that's
providing it with longevity
he says the copy of the same tune that's
printed in my volume of the scottish
student songbook
typical dawkins there right having a
book that none of us would
is unlikely to last much longer but i
expect there will be copies of the same
tune on paper
and in people's brains for centuries to
come
so if a meme is a scientific idea he
says its spread will depend on how
acceptable it is to the population of
individual scientists
we might you know count the number of
times it's referred to in successive
years in scientific
journals if it's a popular tune we might
gauge it by the number of people
heard whistling it in the streets and
actually i think that's a much better
index if we were able to pull that off
than
you know how many records it sold or
whether
it's um you know made its way into
american idol or guitar hero whether
people actually
do understand and respond to that song
is probably a measure of that
what about fecundity okay so this is how
well
it's able to reproduce itself
he says as in the case of genes
fecundity is much more important than
longevity of particular
copies right so being able to
catch on being able to reproduce itself
and this is where we get to the third
thing copying fidelity
it might be that fecundity
in the case of some genes actually
responds on a degradation
of copying fidelity right simplification
of things so and he brings up
interestingly charles darwin he says
that um
when we say biologists believe in
darwin's theory
we don't mean that every biologist has
graven in his brain an identical copy of
the exact words of charles darwin
himself
each individual has his own way of
interpreting darwin's ideas
he probably learned them not from
darwin's own writings but from more
recent authors
much of what darwin said is in detail
wrong darwin if he read
this book would scarcely recognize his
own original theory in it though i
hope he would like the way i put it yet
in spite of this there is something
some essence of darwinism which is
present in the head of every individual
who understands the
theory so he says that this is
you know the way in which we have some
degree of
copying fidelity so that's an
interesting point
we also want to think about what counts
as competition
for memes so he uses the analogy of
computer
memory back in the time that he's
writing you would have to kind of
compete
in research projects to get computers
now we have so many computers
people do still have to compete and now
it's more like our own programs are
competing with each other
like chrome uses a lot of uh memory for
the computer
more than other browsers right so in a
way
memes are like that how much headspace
how much brain neuron connections do
they
take up and connect with that's one
question
but he also talks about externalized
spaces
billboards newspaper
uh space uh spaces in journals and books
at libraries we might talk about the
internet itself and
go back to computer metaphors and say
well how many sites are
actually using this particular meme
or generating it right and so
that's how they compete with each other
they compete with each other in what we
might call
to use a term that he's not using here
the attention economy how much
attention are we giving them uh if i'm
paying attention to this song over here
you know
for example judas priest breaking the
law and i've got that stuck in my head
as an
ear worm that i'm not actually hearing
iron maidens the trooper
even though they're in the same genre
and actually quite close to each other
in time
and originating out of the same we might
say meme
soup of heavy metal right so they can
compete with each other in in
that way they might also although he
doesn't suggest this refer to each other
in
interesting ways as well and memes
to complicate this a bit further
memes he says can be subdivided so if we
take darwin's theory for example if it
consists in a number of different points
that we might accept some of and
disagree about
others those are separate memes so now
memes can be broken down
further into other memes and they might
also be associated in
meme complexes to take the issue of the
symphony
and the first you know 12 bars of it
the first 12 bars if they're
recognizable might be a meme
particularly if they're used in
commercials or dawkins brings up being
used for the introduction
of a a television show
but the symphony itself can be
considered to be one
big meme that's a conglomeration of
other
memes and he interestingly points out if
you have too much of the
single bit in your head you might
actually not be able to
appreciate the symphony as a
whole so memes turn out to be
quite complicated they are they really a
unit of cultural transmission in the
sense of being like an atom that we
stick together with other
atoms not exactly they
can connect with each other they can
fuse into each other or break up into
separate memes
so unit is being used here in a much
more relational
way than you know we might say with with
genetic materials where there's
something a bit more
discreet that we can look at but even
with genetic materials we can have gene
complexes as he pointed out
so this is the conception that dawkins
has
of a meme at the time that he's writing
the selfish gene
obviously there has been some cultural
evolution
in terms of the concept of meme that has
resulted in
alternate understandings of meme that
have propagated themselves in
culture in ways going beyond but perhaps
explicable
through dawkins very concept
you